germany could soon impose stricter
coronavirus restrictions
chancellor angela merkel is due to meet
leaders of the country's
16 states partial lockdown measures were
introduced
only two weeks ago closing bars
restaurants and museums
despite this new cases have not dropped
significantly
according to the german public health
authority new infections rose by nearly
11 000
on monday
joining me and now for more is dw chief
political uh
edit editor michael what can we expect
from today's meeting there well we can
definitely expect
tighter measures um we've had access to
the draft document
and there it states that although
germany has managed to get out of an
exponential phase of re-infections
and infections rather this is seen as a
small success but also seen is not
enough
to sp to prevent the german health
services from being overstretched
uh intensive care units are up to 70
percent and sometimes
beyond capacity and and that's why
germans have to brace themselves for yet
more contact restrictions clearly a
focus
on how many people meet each other at
any
point in time one of the proposed
measures there is that when people meet
in public it's no longer
just two households are allowed to meet
it's only one person allowed to meet
with
two members of another household so more
restrictions there and a call
for absolute minimum contact also
including requirements
for masks in schools there's been very
different pictures according to which
region in germany you speak of
so more to come for the german public
which is increasingly concerned that
this disease might actually
personally affect them a pretty grim
outlook in an interview with with
germany's built amizontag newspaper the
germany's economy minister peter
altmaier said he expects that germany
quote
will have to live with considerable
precautions and restrictions
for at least the next four to five
months germans have been told
that we have a lockdown light for four
weeks now this what's your take on that
well that pretty much tails in with the
timeline that
seems to be crystallizing out of this
very promising
prospect of actually having vaccinations
within reach
over the coming months there's an
expectation here by the company by on
tech
that is producing this vaccine that it
could be ready to go
at the beginning of next year and by the
time this is
able to reach enough people to make a
real difference
that could be a couple of months from
now health authorities for now are being
told that they should be
ready to start max mass vaccinations by
mid december already so clearly
preparation is on the way there
i want to talk about this a new campaign
launched by
the german government is called be a
hero and is essentially encouraging
people
to stay home and be couch potatoes so
let's just check it out this version is
subtitled
by an english twitter user let's have a
look
[Music]
[Music]
by the german government seeking support
for strict
coronavirus uh measures um after
it's a country germany is a country that
has seen some of the biggest anti-lock
down
protests here do germans have really
have the stomach for
for more restrictions yes they do
um some three-quarters of germans
see the current restrictions in place as
adequate
and some of them even feel that they
should be even tighter so for now
angela merkel has incredible support
it's been rising throughout this crisis
and germans do have the stomach for it
now although there is a
very small but very loud group that is
firmly against these restrictions i
think the clip there most of all is
proof uh if we need any but we often do
that there is a german sense of humor
also when it comes to the public
authorities and it's a very tangible
example
that the focus when we see new
restrictions being
announced today is once again more on
the individual's responsibility
and not authorities being able to
control something like how many people
meet at any one time
so it's the firm message that the onus
is on every individual to ensure that
this doesn't get out of control
our chief political address
coronavirus testing labs have long since
reached their limits in germany in an
attempt to ease the pressure
a new strategy is in place for the
winter now with fewer tests but targeted
at those who need
them most and also more rapid tests
but the new strategy comes with
challenges as we discovered
at one hospital in berlin
a coronavirus test to make sure this
patient's not infected
ahead of her operation in a few days
time
it doesn't hurt exactly but it's very
unpleasant it feels like the swab is
poking around in your brain
the test is obligatory to protect other
patients and staff at hospitals like
this one in berlin
but many people in germany would like
the chance to be tested more regularly
it would be good if we could use the
tests to make things like traveling
easier
to be a bit safer
that doesn't look likely any time soon
with testing capacity at its limits the
government is trying to ease the
pressure on overworked labs
even some hospitals are shifting away
from the more reliable pcr tests instead
using the faster cheaper antigen tests
to check their staff for the virus
the advantage of rapid tests is that we
get a result within 30 minutes
it's relatively reliable and a
relatively easy testing system
but on the other hand the disadvantage
is that we know the rapid tests are
slightly less sensitive to the virus
the pcr test is the gold standard it's
more precise than the rapid test
is it's a fine balance between what's
reliable
and what's practical but the rapid tests
come with their challenges too
in germany they can only be administered
by a trained health worker
that costs time and money and means
people can't test themselves at home
nurse eve baumann understands the
dilemma
as hospital staff of course we would
have liked to keep using the pcr tests
because they're more sensitive
but i understand that the labs are at
their limit and we need the pcrs more
urgently for the patients
when they arrive with symptoms then we
have to know fast but for sure whether
they really have coronavirus or not
boarman gets tested once every two weeks
enough to feel safe he says
but it's clear any hopes testing could
be rolled out on a broader scale will
have to wait
for many that means a test of patience
instead
let's take a look now at some of the
other developments in the global
pandemic
the united states has now surpassed 11
million cases that's the highest number
in the world despite the us having
less than five percent of the world's
population
starting thursday new zealand will have
to where new zealanders rather will have
to wear masks on public transport in
auckland and plains
nationwide this comes after several
small outbreaks in auckland
and authorities in south australia are
warning of a dangerous situation after a
spike on monday followed
months without any locally acquired
cases
over the weekend lebanon began a
two-week lockdown to curb the spread of
kovitt 19 health officials called the
country's situation critical with
hospital capacity at a saturation point
but many dread the economic impact of
the restrictions as the country already
faces its worst financial crisis in
decades
lebanon enters another lockdown the few
people out on the streets of beirut are
wondering how they are going to make
ends meet
basically not going to work for two
weeks my my salary in the next month
is going to be like so low so low
so i don't know the country is
registering around 2 000 new coronavirus
cases every day
and its intensive care units are at 95
percent
capacity that's prompted the government
to urge people to put their health
first and not the economy
we have reached the red line we've
reached a stage of critical danger
and we dread reaching a stage where
people are dying in the streets
authorities hope that this lockdown will
give the country's health system a
chance to recover
but not everyone is convinced the
restrictions will make a difference
many people are coming to the pharmacy
having corona
and they are not committed to the
lockdown they are going
uh and they are going outside without
face masks so we need to be more
committed
others are respecting the lockdown rules
but with lebanon's hospital
short of hundreds of doctors the country
likely has a rough road ahead before it
can get a grip
on the pandemic